messieurs bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france pour
livrer vos impressions après le discours
d' emmanuel macron devant le parlement
européen pour commencer avant d'aller
dans les détails peut-être votre
première impression qu'est ce que vous
retenez de cette prise de parole
françois poulet mathis
france qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
assisté là un exercice de démocratie
directe qui n'en existe que très peu
dans le reste du monde et dans le reste
des institutions de la planète puisque
pour la première fois au moins
responsables de l'exécutif à chefs
d'état soumis directement à des
questions et des interpellations de
députés demandent la parlement ont ça
c'était un élément qui me paraissait
très intéressant dans cet exercice le
deuxième point qui m'a paru intéressant
c'est que emmanuel macron n'a pas jugé
vouloir être très près de route yeux sur
l'avenir en europe affiché une certaine
modestie une certaine retenue il a avoué
lui-même que l'europe de sa jeunesse ni
avec lui un moment mais que les épisodes
2000 2005 notamment de discorde une
incompréhension de la population
européenne par rapport au fonctionnement
cette europe l'avait aussi troublé et
donc il souhaitait à nouveau sous
trouver un élan créateur un petit peu
nouveau donc ça c'est un élément d'une
certaine forme de modestie pour le reste
effectivement il ya deux choses que je
retiens la première chose ce qu'il ya
une proposition qui a été renforcée par
le changements politiques intervenus en
allemagne où il propose échange est un
élément vraiment nouveau politiquement
c'est la possibilité d'une initiative
directe du parlementaire en matière
législative gtd que le parlement
européen pourrait disposer d'un droit à
l'initiative est simple et ça c'est très
important puisque effectivement ça c'est
une réponse à l'impossibilité seulement
des peuples de s'échapper mais avec
suffisamment d'efficacité dans le cadre
de cette union européenne ont chassé
nouveau une derniers éléments sur le
plan de la politique extérieure
effectivement de réagir des lots on
parlait de l'art
la nécessité pour d'en être clair on pas
être diffusée dans ses positions
elle se manifeste par deux choses d'une
part que tous les européens discutent
entre eux pour les redéfinir les raisons
d'une alliance stratégie on appelle une
moue seule stratégie mais en même temps
se définir des principes qui sont
fondamentaux il n'est pas question de
revenir sur le droit de chaque état de
définir quels sont le choix de leur
alliance autrement dit pas de jaune d'
influence ne revenons pas la guerre
froide on sait que nos éléments qui me
paraissent intéressants qui m'ont pas
réellement frappé dans cette
intervention nicolas dupont aignan
françois boulay mathis nous parlait à
l'instant d'une certaine modestie de la
part du chef de l'état française que
vous vous partagez ce constat qu'est ce
que vous retenez de de la prise de
parole de dudu du président emmanuel
macron
ça fait 20 ans qu'on entend toujours les
mêmes choses
si vous voulez ya des belles intentions
le problème de fond c'est que ces belles
intentions ne peuvent pas mal être
appliquées ou ne peuvent pas être
traduites en actes par cette structure
européenne qui ne marche pas donc des
dix roues comme ça on en a eu 50 plus
personne ne les écoute parce qu'ils ne
veulent rien dire je vous donne un
exemple très simple la sphère du marché
de l'énergie
c'est le système de l'union européenne
qui a cassé edf en france et qui fait
que les prix de l'électricité explose
puisque on s'est lié les mains réclame
man est donc né français
qui peuvent plus vivre avec leur
porte-monnaie
voit très bien que le président a depuis
fait des grands discours il se met en
scène c'est la communication c'est du
grand cinéma
si je le reconnais le défi l'afrique est
fondamentale le défi du numérique est
fondamental
paix avec la russie et instruments de
l'union européenne avec la commission
avec les lobbys avec la lourdeur
bureaucratique
qui est en place n'est pas le bon
c'est comme si vous et décoller avec un
avion un prototype qui s'écrase à chaque
fois vous pouvez monter dans l'avion ne
démarre des achats pas vous écrase
vous croyez qu'on va établir des
relations avec la russie avec la pologne
et les états baltes du coup comment est
ce que l'on est ce que vous auriez axé
votre discours vous si vous aviez été à
sa place
à moi j'aurais très tout de suite dit
c'est une union ne marche pas parce que
la commission de bruxelles a voulu
s'occuper des compétences des nations et
ne s'occupe pas des sujets fondamentaux
qui permettrait à l'europe de compter
dans le monde
rendons nation leur liberté de
frontières nationales leur budget leur
loi et en revanche c'est ce que je
propose en mon projet présidentiel
proposons une europe confédérale
imaginé par général de gaulle qui ne
s'occupe que de grands projets à la
carte qui sont comme on l'a fait airbus
ariane sans la bureaucratie européenne
epa à 27
préparons un projet des dalles afrique
acca toussaint pays sur la barrière
verte au sahel sur la transition
démographique sur l'agriculture
africaine préparons un gafa européen
c'est-à-dire une entreprise un facebook
européen à deux ou trois pays e et puis
entamant une grande réconciliation avec
la cie avec les pays qui le vol en
enlevant les sanctions à l'égard de la
russie la russie a les ressources
naturelles la russie a joué un rôle clé
au moyen-orient contre l'islamisme nous
avons besoin nous entendre avec la
russie et il faut arrêter avec cette
division absurde du continent européen
comme le disait le général de gaulle qui
est derrière moi l'europe de
l'atlantique à l'oural et c'est pas avec
le temps qu'on construira l'europe donc
d un moment il faut arrêter de croire
qu'on peut avancer à 28 on avancera rien
à 28 cette structure est morte il faut
non pas le fric site parce que moi je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse est seul en
europe il faut travailler dans une
europe à la carte autour de projets
concrets et là vous verrez que les
peuples et moraux l'europe quand les
nations seront lit de contrôler leurs
frontières
de défendre leurs intérêts et quand on
travaillera sur des projets communs un
petit nombre de pays si je devais
conclure c'est exactement pour comme un
syndicat de copropriété dans une
copropriété dans un immeuble le syndic
il s'occupe pas de la couleur de votre
moquette et l'heure de votre repas et et
il n'a pas enlevé la porte de notre
appartement
moi je veux un syndic de copropriété qui
ne s'occupe que des parties communes et
je veux qu'on retrouve la liberté
nationale
dont je ne crois absolument pas à ce
discours qui n'est que du vent qui
n'apportera rien qui est comme les
discours concert l'onu ça sert à rien et
j'aimerais que la france défendre ses
intérêts et que la france est à vis des
coopérations concrètes pour créer des
projets face à la chine et aux états
unis car l'avenir ce sera notre capacité
scientifique d'innovation face à la
chine et aux états unis c'est le reste
n'est que de la littérature françois
poulet mathis nicolas dupont aignan
menée en parlait emmanuel macron propose
à l'europe de s'allier à l'otan pour
pour contrer la russie quel est votre
regard sur cette proposition
il s'agit pas forcément de s'allier
contre la russie il s'agit de s'allier
pour redéfinir le manière un peu plus
clair qu'elle menait actuellement ce
qu'on appelle un objectif stratégique il
quelles sont véritablement d'où viennent
les dangers etc c'est ça l'essentiel de
la redirection de la re division
stratégie que veut emmanuel macron en
redéfinissant collectivement nos
rapports entre nous sur ce que l'on veut
véritablement formateur en amérique et
le faire en liaison avec le temps et une
fois qu'on l'a fait avec le temps on
s'adresse à la russie pour négocier avec
elle dans les meilleures conditions sur
quelques principes encore une fois
qu'ils doivent pas être remis en cause
dont le principe que la zone d'
influence mais quelque chose que
l'europe ne peut pas accepter ne peut
plus accepter nous ne sommes plus dans
une bière froide la deuxième chose que
je voudrais lire j'entendais nicolas
dupont aignan définir qu'il faut une
europe des projets concrets et non pas
une europe technocratique
nous on est d'accord sur le fait que ne
rend pas été trop des petits craquements
de ton texte classique mais le rhum des
projets c'est bien ce qui a été fait au
départ la ceca le charbon et l'acier
leurs atomes et puis par la suite il n'y
aura pas de l'école et puis par la suite
l'europe nucléaire et par la suite
lavoine et unique solution des projets
concrets c'est là dessus que s'est
construit l'europe sur des projets
concrets et non pas sur mais pour des
cocktails que nos pratiques latex de
trachée c'est vrai elle s'est imposée
par la suite c'est trop apogée et cela
nécessite des réformes mais dire que
l'europe n'est pas construite sur des
réalités tangibles c'est faux notamment
en ce qui concerne la pandémie la
pandémie est ce que l'europe
individuellement à ce que chaque nation
aurait pu négocier individuellement
l'obtention de vaccins est ce que chaque
l'action aurait pu chacun est à venir
une stratégie autonome vis-à-vis de
cette pandémie c'est pas possible il
faut être ensemble pour être plus
efficace c'est ça l'art et emmanuel
macron nicolas dupont aignan c'est vrai
à a salué cette europe face à face à la
pandémie vous savez aussi cette
solidarité européenne pour faire face
aux cocos vide
mais d'abord je veux répondre au début
oui l'europe était sur des projets
concrets c'était une europe confédérale
les nations garder leur liberté et puis
ensuite ça a été complètement transférée
à la commission de bruxelles et les
projets qui ont marché tous les projets
qui ont marché ont été faits en dehors
de l'union européenne airbus ariane les
seuls projets qui ont marché était en
dehors de l'union européenne à chaque
fois que vous partez par l'union
européenne c'est la défaite de l'europe
face à la chine et aux états unis donc
c'est pas la commission européenne c'est
la commission américaine ou chinoise ce
sont des lobbys donc arrêter avec ce
cinéma c'est faux deuxième point sur la
pandémie je suis désolé
l'europe à additionner ses faiblesses et
sa soumission à pfizer avec l'achat de
vaccins sans responsabilité du fabricant
sans divulgation des contrats personne
n'a le droit de regarder les contrats et
l'europe c'est complètement soumise à la
pensée unique et aboutit à un désastre
sanitaire alors qu'on arrête avec la
solidarité c'est pas de la solidarité
c'est la solidarité avec file ou madame
brand der leyen a remis un prix à son
copain pdg de file et a acheté pour des
dizaines de milliards d'euros e sans que
le vaccin soit transmis dans le bien
public de l'humanité si on croit au
vaccin pourquoi alors l'europe n'a pas
milité pour que ce vaccin deviennent le
brevet soit transmis à l'humanité non
l'europe est à genoux devant les
multinationales
c'est une commission qui est au service
des multinationales et qui ne défend pas
les pubs dernier point sol sur la sphère
de l'otan et la russie enfin c'est
n'importe quoi tout le monde sait qu'à
partir du moment où l'union européenne
se met dans les mains de l'otan il peut
pas y avoir de paix avec la
c'est impossible puisque l'ouest n'a
jamais respecté la russie jamais
respecté la russie au moment de la chute
prs s il était convenu au départ que
l'ukraine et toute la bande du milieu
zone or autant avancer le temps mais ça
allait très bien cieux eux ce qui a été
perçu comme une provocation par poutine
si on veut la paix avec la russie il
faut arrêter de passer par le temps la
france doit renouer ses relations avec
l'italie avec ce qu'ils le volent avec
ce grand peuple russe travailler avec la
russie ait arrêté de céder un souvenir
de la guerre froide qui entraîne
l'europe dans un suicide alors que le
vrai danger aujourd'hui c'est la chine
et nous devons faire bloc avec la russie
au lieu de recréer des réminiscences de
guerre froide c'est une aberration
géopolitique
merci messieurs on pourra effectivement
en débattre pendant des heures
malheureusement on arrive au terme du
temps qui nous est imparti merci en tout
cas messieurs d'avoir réagi sur rtl
france merci à vous françois paul et
mathis journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes merci à vous
nicolas dupont aignan candidat debout la
france à la présidentielle